failed former president donald trump did
a rally this weekend in ohio in support
of vile republican candidate for the
senate jd vance now very often when
trump does these speeches we go through
the entire speech looking at little bits
and pieces i'm not going to do that
today today i want to take a different
approach i'm going to focus in on two
specific rants rants that only a very
delusional and unhinged person would
ever deliver now don't be confused trump
did all the normal stuff that he does at
these rallies he claimed he won in 2020
he says socialists have taken over the
democratic party he says mail-in ballots
are fraud he did all of that but i want
to focus on two areas that are so absurd
that they're almost comical i've told
you before
how donald trump has seemed obsessed
with water pressure plumbing and toilets
and many of you think that that's a joke
but he really is and he went on one such
rant now i'm gonna do something that i
don't normally do
i'm going to play the whole toilet rant
for you together
just to give you a sense of how sick
this guy is stick with it it's minutes
long but that's the point here
this is what he's doing at a rally i
said we're going to do something about
it and we did that with many industries
but that one i went up to the whirlpool
factory where they make it and it was
incredible and that's
washers dryers all of that stuff the
dishwashers
and then we changed some rules too you
know i said what's the problem can we
help you well they don't give us any
water for the dishwasher what does that
mean
that we don't have enough water you know
what the ladies usually mostly the
ladies in some cases just to protect
myself as far as trump knows it's
usually women washing dishes in some
cases the men
okay
he'll say it was a terrible thing he
said he said only the ladies what no no
there's some men out there too they're
not so happy about it either
but in the dishwashers as an example
they had a little problem what was the
problem they didn't give you any water
and there was so little water that you
couldn't wash the dishes so what do
people do this is an issue trump knows a
lot about saying do it again do it again
do it again so by the time you do it 10
times the dishes are finally there
you've wasted a lot of electricity and
you spend more water than if you did it
right
so i had a regulation where i let you
have all the damn water you want for
your dishes now of course this is all a
lie like i have one of these you know
modern dishwashers that doesn't use a
lot of water i don't even have to scrape
the dishes i mean they just they come
out perfectly every time
and the same thing for your closing
same thing for your clothing for your
dish
for your dishwasher is great but for
your washes and dryers in the washers
they had no water coming out and i just
asked these simple questions to the head
of whirlpool who the hell knows better
than him i said you have a problem yeah
the problem is
there's not enough water i also did it
by the way
for your sinks you ever go to a new home
you buy a nice new home because of the
trump policies hopes were going up like
crazy by the way i hate to tell you the
stock market dropped over a thousand
points
free association of ideas all over the
place but he eventually gets back to his
favorite which is toilets on friday
lots of luck everybody
but you ever go into a new home and you
turn on the faucet
and there's no water comes out they have
restrictions and you know we're talking
about places you don't have a water
problem a lot of say most states don't
have a water problem in fact you do have
a water problem you have too much water
you don't know what to do with it
so they have restrictors so you're
sitting there washing your hands and
it'll come on water come out baby i want
to wash i have to tell you
if this guy hadn't been president of the
united states like in a normal country
where this guy wouldn't be elected this
would actually be hilarious like this is
hilarious but they made this guy
president i got rid of it
same thing with showers i'd go into a
shower
and i'd go to a hotel that was new and i
said i can't stay in these places why
the water just drips out a little bit
slowly i want to take good care of my
hair
i don't want that no it's true
i mean i put the soap in it takes you 20
minutes to have the water come out to
get the damn soap out of your hair
but uh
and i won't talk about the third element
of the bathroom because every time i do
the fake news only talks about yep he
when he when he goes his real passion is
toilets and flushing them 10 to 15 times
but he gets punished when he talks about
it
but you know what i'm talking about
one time two times five times ten times
no water comes out so
can anybody in the audience tell me if
you've had to flush the toilet ten times
i mean really you know in all honesty
trump is obsessed with this and i don't
know what he's flushing we know
sometimes he flushes secret documents
maybe that's why he's flushing ten times
i
totally
took that out and we
made it so that when you have a sink you
can actually wash your hands normally
and you can take a shower
and you can do that other thing normally
all right the third element of the
bathroom
so we did it with the dryers we did
so guys this it's insane it's a
three-minute rant about plumbing
then trump unprovoked brings up the
dementia test okay starts out of thin
air there's no rhyme or reason and again
we're doing this a little differently
this is the full dementia rant and lis
he's bragging about it it's he thinks
it's an iq test it's just meant to
screen for serious dementia dr ronnie
and many doctors and i aced it and you
know now they don't call me stupid they
say he's a dictator he wants to take
over the world
you know they used to call me jd uh they
made they said maybe stupid so i said
to doc ronnie you know doc ronnie is now
a great congressman in texas great very
popular guy i think he won by like 52
points or something right but he's now a
great congressman i said ronnie
i don't like when people call me stupid
i had great heritage an uncle who was a
great great genius by the way great
heritage i guess trump thinks he's
predisposed to be smart because his
uncle was smart is it weird heritage
it's almost like saying he had good
blood father who is a genius everybody
or else we have a lot of geniuses i
don't like being called stupid is there
a test or something i can take to prove
to these radical left maniacs yeah the
test would maybe be an iq test even
though that's questionable not just a
dementia screening that i'm much smarter
than them is there a test and he said
sir there is a test it's called a x test
i said what's it like he said well it's
uh it gets very tough the first
questions are easy
and the middle of the test gets tough
and now we all know it doesn't get tough
we went we've gone through the test it's
the montreal cognitive assessment the
test is quite tough sir actually
i said well
what happens if i don't do well
he said well you know it's uh it's at
this great hospital you know our great
military hospital we all know our
military hospital and the system is
incredible incredible doctor so i said
walter reed i said
uh
by the way it's just a piece of paper
you don't even really need to go to a
hospital to take this test it's just
it's a single piece of paper let me take
it
he said sir here's the problem if you
don't do well everyone's going to be
reading about it at the front pages now
of course that's not true because they
would if he didn't do well they would
just never talk about it i said and i if
i do do well nobody's going to talk
about it that's the way it works with
the fake news they don't talk about it
so i said he said and other people are
present while you're taking it sir
i said let's go dr ronnie give me that
goddamn test right
i want to take that test
give me that test stuck running
so they gave it to me and they start
asking questions and some you know
around the third or fourth or fifth
question sir
sir
name five things
they named five things a light
a group of people now trump here is
struggling to even do it he's actually
struggling
ohio
a fake teleprompter that i never end up
using
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and the fake news
thank you sir very much thank you then
they come back to you 20 minutes later
name the five things you named
and i hid it perfectly that's pretty
tough it's like a hole in one in golf
it's really tough to do they say nobody
hits that one and when we told that you
know we told it on fox i hope fox gets
all straightened out all right i can't i
really can't do anymore um
bragging about a dementia test and
saying it makes him really really smart
so a bizarre rally one more clip there
were the normal glitches here is trump
struggling to say dropbox no more
dropbox
drop boxes are just so bad no more all
right so listen this is a guy who if he
was not president at one point would be
hilarious this would be absolutely
hilarious it would almost be it would
almost be lovably hilarious my dementia
test and i'm mad about flushing toilets
he was president
and he was using those toilets to flush
secret documents and it is absolutely
horrifying
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video